the Joe Rogan experience yeah what do
you how do you feel about edibles I love
them to sleep on mm-hmm I love chocolate
I got you is what my wife and I both use
oh yeah we'll wake up in the middle of
the night instead of you know fussing
and fighting nerve you know thinking
about it we just go and get a little
little chocolate thing it's delicious
chocolate - its de francy chocolate and
it's it's the best thing and you just
sleep not only I slept last night but I
had a couple of them epiphanies yeah
that just blew my mind and what how art
is going to save the world and art does
can save the world
yeah how's that well you look at history
the pyramids that was art that was an
art piece and what happens when you when
you have big huge art pieces like that
you create employment and it's not war
so you're not fighting you're creating
and so the people that that care for the
animals the people that have to feed the
the mass of people that have to work on
getting those rocks carving those rocks
everything else it creates employment
and and it also creates tourism and so
you when you have a piece of art
everybody wants to come and look at it
and so that's what we need in the world
today you see and we not only need art
but we need functional art because
that's what the pyramids were they were
functional and a lot of people think it
was the the astronauts you know in
aliens the aliens in which which could
very well be yeah think so sure for sure
for sure why do you think that well
because there's nothing new in the
universe you know we've had space
flights we've had all that stuff forever
but you have Chung's choice cooler pipe
yeah that genius pipe that's new in the
universe that's that's no it's it's
probably rehashed know somewhere in the
world we have someone ya know so in the
universe oh you talk about if you want
to talk about part two Chinese India
north
all religion what makes you think that
aliens built the pyramids oh well I'm
saying they could have been really I I
think aliens are just humans you know
that because if they're wearing
spacesuits if they're aliens why did
they need a spacesuit unless he did come
from another atmosphere III personally
believed that earth is the only planet
in this universe and the reason I
believe that is that there are countless
universes like space is endless and so
space is in this why wouldn't we have
our own universe okay so you think that
earth is the only planet in this
universe yes but what about Mars well
it's a dead planet
okay so earth is the only live planning
the amount with life in this whole
universe yeah so you think that there's
multiple universes or infinite numbers
of universe yes in each universe
probably has unearthed or two or two but
you think this whole universe of
hundreds of billions of galaxies yes
with hundreds of billions of solar
systems could be there's only one planet
could be because we have the space so
the only you mean by one planet one
planet with life yes but what elegantly
but why wouldn't you think that there's
because it's so big why wouldn't you
think there could possibly be other life
other places why couldn't it be the
other way why couldn't we be the only
ones we could be that's what I'm saying
we totally could be so so there's no
reason for me see see that's why I have
people trouble with people that are
afraid of a you know artificial
intelligence yeah I think so silly
because well because they're smart
they're smart enough to know that
they're not going to inflame anybody or
torture anybody or take over anything
no the only dummies do that stuff yeah
because when you capture something you
know what you capture well their
problems whatever their problems are not
sixteen you extinguish them yeah for
what reason well the people are just
destroying the earth they're polluting
the rivers they're sucking all the fish
out of the sea it's not this guy's
filled with carbon the artificial life
is gonna be like you know one through
goddamn people their dirty little
litters - choking squirrels z that's the
paranoid look at it look at the positive
again what's the positive well first of
all you have to remember we live in a
physical universe okay
for every action there's a reaction so
for every good there's a bad nothing
explains trunk more than for every Obama
there's a trump know what I'm saying
okay so there's no limit to how ignorant
you can be and there's no limit to how
smart you can be there's no limit and so
when you go up the scale to the
intelligence scale then then you realize
that there is no reason for it to be
paranoid about anything because if you
it's all written out and know all the
holy books and written it out you know
especially the Bible see the Bible has
been misconstrued by so many people
because what they do they take it to
what's going to suit their purposes and
then but but to really interpret the
Bible it's written in code it's written
it's a secret code yeah it's
metaphysical terms it's not physical
terms or metaphysical terms what do you
know about the bottom one cold look
there's a writer called Emmett Fox
should get into him yeah he deciphers
the whole bible does he decipher the
ancient hebrew version of the Bible or
the Greek version the Bible Latin all
the versions right but I mean it all
comes from ancient Hebrew and when you
translate things from ancient Hebrew yes
you know ancient Hebrew the letters also
doubles numbers sure yeah and and see
see with the people I read there's
another mystic that I read a long stick
wise mystic you know you know he's not
he but his name is Joel s goldsmith yeah
I discovered him a long time ago but I
discovered him in jail it's a very
popular book in jail and goldsmith look
him up he's all on the computers and
everything let's check him out yeah
you'll really really enjoy it
new perspective because what he
maintains it's all britman like I say in
the Bible eternity
say there's no beginning and no end that
explains everything to me because if
there's no beginning to no end what can
well it can happen will happen you know
mm-hmm and because this is again this is
my theory it's in the physical world we
have to learn everything that's why
everything's physical like the first
thing when you're born you have to learn
how to breathe you have to learn how to
walk you have to learn how to eat mm-hmm
these are all skills that you have to
literally learn right in Mother's and
everything teaching you that and then
when you reach a certain age you leave
the planet you know at least your soul
your spirit the body the body stays but
it's just a vehicle and so because of
eternity this goes on and on and on and
on forever
it never stops what we do as humans
we're learning we're creatures of worth
we're all students whether we want to be
or not you know I was trying to explain
this to my one son because my youngest
son is a bit he's a musician you know
and and I and I try to understand that
he's a musician and you know musicians
are that you know they're not
entrepreneurial as some people would
like him to be but anyway everybody's
sure to learn a certain task and some of
us are blessed in to the point like me
I'm blessed and very blessed because
I've been given the ability to do what I
do and to see what I see and to say what
I say you know it doesn't come from me
it comes from you know the source what I
call the source
[Applause]